we need to bring back the right to
offend people yes it used to be that
thinking that cultures can be better or
worse was not a controversial thing and
for some reason now we're not allowed to
say the values that the chinese
communist party stands for are horrific
there are people inside of twitter that
are trying to suppress content that is
not in the interest of the ccp we're now
having a very serious argument about
whether or not teaching gender ideology
to five-year-olds is a good thing we're
definitely going to see a whole new wave
of different ethnicities that reject
american progressiveness we've had a
generation of people trying to convince
us that america was bad the world is
about to end because of climate change
what we need to do is say hey we've made
some mistakes but we need to bring back
the ideals and values that we had before
do you think that america's future is
brighter or darker all right guys bang
bang i've got lucas here with me uh i'm
very excited to have this conversation i
thought a great place to start would be
with tick tock which is now the most
visited website in the world uh it has
taken american uh teenagers by storm but
there's a dark side to this and there's
a lot of folks who are issuing warnings
about
maybe america shouldn't be embracing a
technology like this help us understand
like what are the risks to something
like a tick tock yeah totally i mean you
know i think back in 2020 we really had
the idea about banning tick-tock
and that was a very good idea that ended
up getting nowhere and realistically
tick-tock is owned by bait dance which
is a chinese company
baitan's for all we know is controlled
by the ccp you know china has a law that
basically allows people
that allows the government to request
any information of any company uh so
effectively any chinese company works
for the ccp
so we have an app that is owned by
a chinese company that is controlled by
the ccp
that is the most used app of every
american every young american in the
country we don't really understand how
they run the algorithms we don't really
understand what they're putting up for
our teenagers to watch
and that's effectively what's been
happening so
algorithms i think are an interesting
component of this argument right which
is uh if i go on facebook if i go on
twitter uh i can look in the news feed
or i can look on my twitter timeline and
i can either choose to get a
uh a feed that is algorithmically
determined they're trying to predict
what i want to watch uh or what i will
engage with or i can choose to have
reverse chronological order which is
just hey i follow a certain number of
people whoever posted last that is kind
of the first thing and i can scroll
through but there's not this algorithmic
or kind of editorial layer on top of it
tick tock my understanding is they don't
have a reverse chronological order
option it is 100 algorithmic and that's
one of the questions i think people are
asking is
are they manipulating that in some way
uh in an adversarial way
for american audiences versus other
countries right and so
that that's what i think it's really
important to hone in on because i think
a lot of the conversations that we had
in 2020 2021 around tik tok were about
the data and perhaps there was an
interesting argument to be made there
but i think it's mostly a distraction uh
you know ultimately we have the ccp
which sees itself in a long struggle
against america that has the control to
potentially put in whatever they want
you know american teenagers to see let's
magnify all the issues that the country
is having let's magnify all the worries
all the concerns that you know this
younger generation is having by you know
controlling what they see now
i don't really understand why
people haven't really taken action
against this realistically imagine if we
were back in the 70s in the cold war
against the soviet union and we had a
major tv channel that was controlled by
the soviet union where all the young
americans at the time wanted to watch
would that like would that be
controversial like
yes
yeah exactly right um and for some
reason now we can't really have that
conversation yeah well if you think even
the united states when we are at war or
sometimes not even actually direct
combat uh but we are trying to um change
the way that people think around the
world like we drop pamphlets all over
certain areas uh with very specific
messaging we did it in the middle east
we've done in many other areas
throughout the years um and in some way
it's psychological warfare uh and we
look at it as we want to inform people
of a different viewpoint or we want to
educate them so that they'll see uh that
it doesn't have to be the way that you
know their country or their city or town
or whatever is run
the
you know that strategy on steroids would
be imagine if they all had an app on
their phone and they had smartphones and
that that is the number one thing that
they consumed and we had the ability to
manipulate the content that was shown to
them
i think that we could probably change
the minds pretty quickly right i mean
that's a very good point you know
ultimately every government in the world
understands the role of propaganda right
like what china could be doing it
probably is doing with tick tock is not
new every counter in america every other
country has done that to countries that
they that they saw as competitors right
um so it's really weird that here in
this situation we can't recognize a
threat that that might be happening and
the impact that could be having
generations in future generations why do
you think
americans are so slow to recognize this
is it because uh their kids use
tick-tock and so they think of it just
as an app no different than twitter or
facebook or instagram or anything else
do you think that it's because uh
there's a lot of former politicians that
are lobbying for tick-tock and so we
just can't get anything done like
why is it that this seems to be
something uh there's a fringe
conversation but not actually resonating
with uh with the mainstream you know i i
think
it's a it's a dangerous conversation to
have because at that point we start
getting a lot into culture uh i think
the the simple version of that argument
is uh the simple answer to it is that at
the end of the day there's a lot of
politicians that you know may just
benefit from the fact that you know
the people that are watching tick tock
now will probably are probably going to
vote for them
um
realistically
i think the the bigger issue that we see
with tick tock today is that over the
last 20 to 30 years
we've actually killed the idea of a
national interest
and we've completely decoupled the idea
of business and the economy
with national security
and you know realistically um i think
that you know people like me like i i
think you and i probably share a common
background that's like libertarian guys
like like bitcoin like rompo like you
know like 20
12 years ago that kind of stuff
and all of that made a lot of sense you
know let's let's get government out of
the way we you know let's globalize the
world um and america is going to benefit
from that
the reality is that did not happen
and as that did not happen america did
not change its strategy
but in the process we actually killed
the idea
that the economy in national interest
should have some something in common
uh and unfortunately that that that is
kind of core to the argument as to
why people don't really care about that
anymore i mean we're going to talk about
the chips at some point but like
talk about something insane that's been
happening right like you have intel that
stands to by the way massively benefit
from all the money that's coming from
the chips act
was heavily lobbying lobbying the
government to try to
stop the government
from trying to curb u.s investments into
chinese into the chinese chip sector
right so intel was saying to the us
government stop allowing u.s investors
to make investments in chinese companies
that are creating no no no or the
reverse the reverse the reverse right
like i mean how insane is that so intel
was actually so the u.s government was
trying to curb u.s investments into the
chinese chip sector and
intel spent records amount of lobbying
money to try to stop the us from doing
that and that's because they wanted more
and more u.s investment to go into these
chinese manufacturers of chips but the
argument uh from the critics of that
strategy would be hey if the united
states continues to increase dependency
on supply chains in china uh we
basically are just exposing ourselves
from a national security standpoint uh
and so it's probably pretty important
that we build our own supply chains
manufacturing capabilities for our chips
uh where we're not reliant on china who
if one day they just turn that off
basically we're [ __ ] exactly i mean
that's exactly right and i think what's
important to highlight there is that
the notion of free markets which i stand
for which i believed in and i've always
believed in
is in some ways at its best an amoral
ideology at its worst you end up people
you end up having companies and having
leaders and having people that choose to
do what's best for them at the expense
of the of what's best for the country uh
and we need to fight back against that
we need to fight back against that hard
i mean realistically right like if we
were having that conversation
in which a u.s company was trying to
uh you know do business with the soviet
union or trying to invest in critical uh
industry and infrastructure for hitler
we would call that person a treat a
trader right
now it's just business as usual yeah
well what's fascinating is uh google
facebook many other companies are not
allowed in china so this is not
something where uh you could argue that
china doesn't think in this way they
have long blocked u.s based technology
companies from servicing their uh
citizens and some people would just
argue oh they want to create a
regulatory moat so that there's chinese
companies that can be built and get
economic progress and can capture that
value
but now it looks like there's a you know
second or an alternative reason for that
which is uh even if the united states
was to say okay we understand that uh
there is a benefit from an entertainment
standpoint or whatever uh for our
citizens to use this application we
don't want to ban it but we're going to
fight back we're going to go on offense
ourselves with some of these platforms
there's nobody who has access to the
china market that's right and this is
one of the most frustrating parts of
this argument which is a lot of times
you talk to people here and you're
saying hey
the stick talk thing is a big deal like
it's a big issue and they're like no no
we can't ban tick-tock that would be too
provocatory towards china i was like
really like we're just asking to level
the playing field that's all it is like
they've treated us like that for decades
right like i mean the amount of money
that companies have spent
trying to dominate the china market only
to
sell
you know whatever was left for nothing
is insane um so we're just saying like
actually like china has you know decided
to treat us like that for a long time
and we're just gonna do the same to them
until we can actually find a middle
ground that works are we as reasonable
are we at war with china or are we
simply in competition with china like
how adversarial is it versus just pure
competition and and there's a
ruthlessness that our competitor is
exhibiting that maybe the united states
isn't willing to exhibit you know i
think that there are different sides to
this argument you know jacob hoberg who
i think you've had on the show uh would
say that we're out war um
and i think where i agree in in with
that argument is
we are at a pretty dire situation
that
most of the country has not really woken
up to yet uh and perhaps calling it a
war uh would actually be very helpful to
get people to really have that sort of
sputnik moment and wake up to the
challenge
the more complicated version of this is
that realistically china sees war in a
way that is different than the american
mind sees it um how does the american
mind see it versus china yeah and i
would point your listeners uh there's a
chinese uh ccp uh book called
unrestricted warfare that was written by
a few chinese generals that now
are very high up in the in the ccp uh
about 25 30 years ago um in that paper
unrestricted warfare basically says that
the american mind and the western mind
think tends to see
uh war as a very in a very black and
white way
uh you either go to war and you send
your soldiers and then you win or you
lose and in reality
china china sees war in a completely
different way um you know there is cyber
warfare there is
propaganda
there is
you know supply chains like and
everything can be a subject of warfare
uh to a given degree so
it's much less black and white and much
more in the spectrum on everything that
can be from a cold war to a hot water so
it's basically there's like direct
combat all the way to indirect
competition or uh influence to some
degree correct and the american culture
american movies american uh approach has
very much been black and white we're at
war we're not i would question that uh
kind of black and whiteness now there
are countries around the world where
we're dropping bombs but we're
technically not at war with them at
least officially and so that seems to
still follow the line of uh we are bombs
bullets soldiers you know that's war
everything else is not um but the
chinese seem to think that maybe the
battlefield uh and kind of more of the
battlefield is the indirect uh
competition and uh influence so things
like the propaganda the psychology the
supply chains all of that seems to be
where they have located and said hey
this is the more important part uh why
is it that they're focused there well
that's where they have always excelled
right so if you look back into the
history of the ccp um there is one of
the best books the best book i've read
all year by the way it's called the long
game by this guy called rush doshi
and doshi goes in and looks at the
history of the ccp and everything that
happened since mao left power
and
china has a you know an aspect of grand
strategy that they have seen nation
buildings uh
you know taking a hundred year mindset
to it uh you know there's this idea of a
national national
rejuvenation
that is pretty big and by the 100 year
anniversary of the founding of the
chinese communist party um
you know they expect china to be the
biggest country in the world to answer
your question specifically why do they
see that
war in such a different way it's because
that's where they can win you know if
you go back to deng xiao xiaoping that
was one of the leaders of the ccp back
in the 70s the mandate of china was
your capabilities and bide your time
um don't show your fangs don't go out to
anybody don't get into conflicts just
build
industries that can take china so that
china by 2050 can become the greatest
nation in the world
and then
back in the 90s in the early 90s
china had what they call the traumatic
trifecta uh you had to go for you had
the fall of the soviet union
and then you had
tiananmen square
and all of those things really
traumatized china and led china to
become much more
military focused than before
you know talk about how china
thinks about fighting a hot war even in
that sense china thinks about very much
asymmetric warfare right so you know if
the us has you know these billion dollar
ships this billion dollar aircraft
carriers um what if we can build like a
million dollar missiles
to get rid of them right i mean that
that's how china would think about
fighting and if you look at you know
their defense infrastructure that's
pretty much what they've built over the
last 20 years right like the u.s is
still very much stuck in this idea of
you know spending billions of dollars to
build this giant things
china is you know spending less money to
build like things that can you know
destroy the u.s infrastructure
with much less money it's fascinating
because the united states are single
greatest military victory in i don't
know the last 20 30 years was we put
like 16 dudes on a helicopter we dropped
them off in the kandahar mountains in
afghanistan and we said go [ __ ] up the
taliban right and we were pretty
successful in doing it and then we went
into and transitioned our strategy from
uh kind of direct action take out a
group of people that
globally i think most people were like
hey these people uh need to be handled
um to a nation-building exercise and
that's where billions and billions of
dollars came in and uh it changed the
way i think that america was engaged uh
across the middle east but specifically
in afghanistan to start and
if you go back to
kind of what worked in the beginning
right if you think of kind of the
military fighting force it was like the
tip of the spear is the single greatest
fighting force in the world and we were
hyper effective
in those early days in afghanistan
but
i don't know why uh we decided to do the
nation building exercise you know
there's the arguments of uh it brought
profits to the defense uh industry there
is uh uh kind of a continuation we
didn't know what else to do um you know
there's some people just hey look it was
a mistake right there's all kinds of
explanations or theories
but to me
there's no difference between let's
build a million dollar missile to take
out a billion dollar piece of
infrastructure then hey let's put you
know 15 16 people on a helicopter and
send them somewhere and let them do
their thing and uh sure there's a lot of
money that goes into training those
people and and uh equipping them and
getting them there and all that stuff
but it sure isn't you know billions if
not trillions of dollars that ends up
getting spent to wage uh kind of these
mechanized wars uh that also then lead
to these nation-building exercises and
it feels like maybe china understands
that and doesn't have an appetite for or
for those kind of bigger
ideas they simply want the more targeted
uh almost sniper-like approach rather
than the bigger uh efforts yeah i would
say i think if you look at the ccp today
i think they definitely have a much
bigger appetite for you know spending
big money on big mess aisles
big ships and all that kind of thing
they have certainly avoided that uh
historically up until you know the last
10 20 years
uh i think now as taiwan comes into play
um chinese defense spending has
definitely gone up quite significantly
they definitely have a lot of aircraft
carriers things that they never did
before i mean the the building of the
first chinese aircraft carrier was
actually a very good point in time that
you can see okay like if you look
historically that's when things started
to shift interesting now on on your
point uh about uh america
you know i think there is this uh
you know joke that the u.s really sucks
fighting wars for the last ever since
vietnam um that's not really true uh you
know realistically i think you cited the
example of the taliban that's 100 true
if you look back at the gulf war i mean
the gulf war was like extremely
effective i mean holy [ __ ] like you look
at at the data
and i don't remember exactly exactly the
number of soldiers but but it was like
like
over 10 000 and the us has like four
casualties or something like that it was
it was incredible uh so us is good at
fighting that the reality is
it is unfeasible to fight those types of
wars uh
in the world today nor necessarily
should we be fighting those fights those
kinds of war in the world today
so
if that's the world that we're living in
how can the u.s adapt to the new reality
of unrestricted warfare
um and this is where i think we have not
necessarily done a good job or evaluated
enough
um this new world that we're living in
because what this means is
everything becomes a battlefield
it's not that we're going to send you
know some soldiers in the desert to
fight this war against the enemies and
they're going to send their soldiers
realistically all of our infrastructure
becomes weaponized
all of our apps become you know a
propaganda
place
um
so if this is the world that we're
living in what are we doing to recognize
the new challenges that we have now that
we didn't have 20 years ago
so we think of let's just take kind of
mobile technologies right so anything go
in your smartphone apps
etc when you look at that should we just
ban every single chinese company from
putting their technology into the
american market is there some sort of
framework or evaluation process that we
should implement and uh should a
government official should a private
organization you know be the one to kind
of execute that evaluation like what do
you think is the solution uh to at least
address um uh the technology side of
what goes on an american citizen's phone
yeah um there's a couple of different
answers to that um i think from a from a
supply chain perspective
i think at the very least we should
recognize that we have a few couple of
very very important rare earths and
minerals and metals that make the supply
chain and and that make basically every
single piece of equipment and technology
that we use today
getting access to those and then getting
access to semiconductors is extremely
important china has a very good degree
of control over that you know i just did
a podcast episode on my podcast uh with
uh nate picarcic that he goes very deep
on that i mean listen to that and you
see like china has actually spent like
20 30 years
really planning how can we actually get
control of those minerals because
they're becoming ever more important
so
you know
having a strategy for how can we
actually get the core items in our
supply chain that we use every day for
basically everything that we need for
every equipment that we use is really
important now
i don't personally think that we need to
ban every single item from china you
know in some ways china has become the
factory of the world
and that actually benefits americans to
some degree you know there's a lot of
low peace equipments that we need
there's a lot of
things that come from china
that the u.s customer can get and that
overall increases the quality of life
of the average america i i could buy
that argument to some degree
but you know the vulnerability that
america has
with
um you know some of these core items of
this on the supply chain is absurd and
we absolutely need to change that what
are some of those areas on the supply
chain that you're like these are our
biggest risks or these are the areas
that we should really be paying
attention to well rare earths and
semiconductors are by far the biggest
issues i mean we're seeing everything
that's happening with uh taiwan and tsmc
we need to change that absolutely um
explain that situation a little bit more
most people i don't think actually
understand
kind of the relationship between china
and taiwan but also tsmc and kind of
their global importance for the
semiconductor industry yeah so um on
china and taiwan
so when the chinese communist party took
over
china
almost 70 years ago
the
party in power fled to taiwan and taiwan
was declared in the independent country
um
realistically china has always
considered taiwan to be part of china
and they have the so-called one china
policy
and it's very controversial in the sense
that
this was never a big deal
and realistically the u.s or the u.n
have never really cared that much
about
recognizing taiwan
uh as a sovereign nation uh
you could you know look historically uh
and you would always find records saying
that taiwan was a sovereign nation but
you know it's not like people were
really really cared about standing up
for that that much
and what happened was um
you know as the semiconductor industry
evolved
um
without getting too into the details
here what you see uh is that every you
know over the last 20 30 years the main
developer of semiconductors became tsmc
not not nvidia not intel it became the
taiwanese company
which make really high quality
semiconductors that we use in basically
every single core piece of technology
today
and in this scenario
as the you know
fight between u.s and china continues to
escalate
china taking over taiwan because becomes
an existential issue for the u.s
realistically you know talk about all
the wars and nation-building things that
the u.s has done over the last 20 years
part of why a lot of people today agree
that like we wasted our time there is
because there was not really a vital us
interest at play in a lot of these wars
we were fighting but we're not really we
didn't really know what we're fighting
for
right
and in the case of taiwan
we actually do need that
if china takes over taiwan it will send
the u.s five to ten years in the past
technologically how easy from a military
standpoint will it be for china to do i
mean china is a massive country as you
said they've made significant investment
in aircraft carriers and various other
military
kind of functionality uh taiwan's not a
huge place population wise not very big
is this something where uh if china
decides to do it
barring some sort of external support
from the united states taiwan stands no
chance of
being able to fight off china
it's it's a complicated answer uh
realistically so president biden
actually said i think six months ago or
less than that that the u.s would
actually fight to defend taiwan that was
the first time that a u.s president has
actually made a statement like that
um and after making a statement like
that if china were to do this
the u.s would either
have to go do something or lose all of
its credibility in addition to that um
over the last two presidencies the u.s
has tried to rebuild what they call the
quad
and build more relationships with
australia and southeast asia uh in you
know countries like japan and south
korea that also don't stand to benefit
from having china become a bully
in asia
so
it would be complicated uh china
certainly has a lot of leverage by the
fact that taiwan
is you know right next door
but
things could get ugly very fast yeah i i
saw um and i forget who who said this
but uh they basically were saying look
uh the taiwanese citizens uh i think
there's like 20 million or so
citizens there they basically need to
hold on for two weeks it would take the
united states uh approximately two weeks
to understand what was happening uh kind
of rally uh get resources equipment
everything to uh taiwan to be able to
help uh kind of support them uh but
those first two weeks would be
incredibly important and if uh uh the
ultimate formula in this person's mind
was just what percent of the citizens
are gonna fight
right right and we see this a little bit
in russia ukraine of uh you know whether
you want to think it was a good idea or
not uh it appears that the ukrainian
government basically turned to their
citizens and said you know we need some
of you to stay uh we will give you guns
we will give you equipment but we need
you to fight and i think that it's a
very uh uh different approach right if
you think in the united states i think
people have a hard time believing uh
because the idea of an invasion uh is
hard to imagine when you have you know
two oceans on either side and uh you
generally have friendly neighbors
but if we were ever in a position where
we said hey in the united states you
need to fight
i wonder what what's the percentage of
people who would fight
right and then you go to some of these
other countries and then ukraine i think
people were surprised by the percentage
of people who stayed the fight right it
was a positive surprise taiwan remains
to be seen what that answer would be
right well um
i don't claim to know taiwanese people
and taiwanese culture
well enough to
you know know what would happen in that
case
but what i do think that you've touched
on that is a slightly different topic
but a very interesting one is
are people really willing to die for
anything today what what happened over
the last 20 years that the idea of
people fighting you know ukrainian
citizens fighting for ukraine
is
inspiring but also like to some degree
mind-boggling in today's culture um
whereas in reality you know fighting for
a country fight fighting for what you
believe in
was always the standard right like that
was life uh and to some degree and by
the way i think it's a positive thing
that
as you know wars
stopped happening and you know we've had
you know to some degree america
being the leading force in the world
you know people don't really believe in
that many things anymore
right uh i mean we have companies today
companies are the core piece of
institutions that we have that it's it's
what is left
but
the idea of national pride the idea of
national culture the idea of religion it
feels like we killed all of those things
over the last 30 to 50 years
and now we have generation of people
that don't really believe in anything
um and you see depression's rate going
up you see
you know nihilism on the rise
um and i think we should sit back and
and you know say like
is this really the world that we want to
live in
and when you look at china how much
nationalism is in the country of china
like is culturally are they following
the global trend and they've lost uh
belief and loyalty and adherence to some
of those ideals uh or are they actually
counter-trend and they are deepening
allegiance and loyalty uh from a
nationalistic view uh and so they're
kind of the outlier yeah um
i wouldn't claim to speak for the whole
chinese culture uh what i can say is
you know when you look at a country that
was going growing 10 a year every year
for the last 20 years or you know
something some really crazy high amounts
the population is going to be happy and
realistically like the population is
going to be on board with whatever
the leading party is in place and that's
true for basically every country that is
experiencing crazy growth that always
happens
um
the answer for the ccp is very clear the
ccp
has a long-term plan to make china
the you know middle kingdom once again
and and this is where it's actually
really hard uh i think for for americans
and people from all over the world to
understand how china thinks about these
things like the u.s is a little bit over
200 years old
china
china has a history of 5 000 years for a
long time china was actually the number
one country in the world
and you know china experienced it not
too long ago from that historical
perspective what they call the century
of humiliation with the opium wars
and then you know the cultural
revolution and all those things you know
where china became an extremely poor
country china had a famine that killed
30 plus million people um
some really hard times and now the
opportunity to once again become the
leading economy of the world
and then the the leading superpower of
the world
so there is a lot of nationalism going
on there is a lot of pride for chinese
culture uh
and
you know
there is a sense of cohesion around the
mission of making china this you know
once again great nation uh and
recognizing that that's what we are
you know being challenged against
is really important how much of american
culture and american companies are
contributing to this kind of china
long-term strategy i'll give you kind of
two examples right so we've got john
cena who uh made some commentary uh
wasn't well received in china it's
important that
movies if you were optimizing purely for
profit get into china he issued an
apology uh basically saying hey you know
taiwan essentially is not an independent
country
which i think shocked a lot of people
and they said what is going on john cena
what are you doing but then also we
recently saw apple has reportedly asked
some of their suppliers to stop labeling
the products made in taiwan and instead
replace them with labels to say made in
china now
it's a report in the mainstream media
you can question the validity of it but
if we accept that that is a true uh
thing that's happening
are american companies and american
culture almost playing right into what
the the chinese
ccp wants to actually occur well they
absolutely are today's episode is
brought to you by alto ira have you
wanted to buy bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with alto ira
they allow you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax-advantaged way
there's no account or set up fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to altoira dot com pomp to get
started alto ira.com
invest in bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies alto ira.com
there is no question about it i i think
it's really hard to argue that we have a
lot of companies today a lot of
influential leaders that are actually
doing what is best for the ccp and not
best for their own country
and it's really bizarre that something
like this is happening you know if you
go back to world war ii
right so world war ii
the us gets attacked the u.s goes to war
and you see companies like gm okay all
the big car manufacturers all the big
manufacturing companies of the us
basically get the message you know what
our business has changed we're not
producing cars
we are now producing
war weapons we're producing airfare like
uh aircrafts
and gm even changed its tagline gm gm
stack line during during the war was
victory israel business
um
and fast forward you know where we are
now we have companies that are more than
happy
to you know follow along the mandates of
the ccp
that are literally telling them what
should what they should be saying
and then go back
in you know in the u.s and you know
gives us give us some you know moral
superiorities spiel on what we should be
thinking right i mean take what's
happened to hollywood right uh
like there was an amazing book that came
out in the last year called the red
carpet the documents the relationship
between hollywood and china
and you know put aside the fact that
you've had a lot of you know hollywood
movie studios get acquired by china you
have a lot of studios that were more
than happy to put in movies what china
told them to put as long as they could
get access to the china to the chinese
market right i mean i remember uh
there's two uh examples that happen here
that are very funny very interesting
one you have there's a movie called the
red scare it's actually a remake of a
sixes movie and it's this idea that you
actually have you know someone from the
soviet union infiltrate someone in
america in a small town and then there
is a communist movement that goes on and
tries to overtake the us government
and it was you know cold war so it was
obvious that you know us was going to
fight against the soviet union
and about 10 20 years ago i don't
remember exactly when they tried they
decided to remake that movie
uh
and there was a you know an obvious
question like who should it be you know
like okay like the soviet union's gone
um
russia doesn't seem like as bad as the
soviet union was back then it should be
china right like china is too owned by
it is still uh ruled by by the chinese
communist party uh it could be the
major challenge to america so they tried
to remake that movie
uh i think the movie was with brad pitt
actually
and when they put china as
uh being the the main challenger to the
us in that movie
china decided to to basically say you're
not doing that and they fought hard
against that and they basically if you
watch the movie the movie actually did
come out
and
i think the i never watched the movie
but
if you look at it the the main
competitor that the us is fighting in
that movie i think it's north korea it's
like this really weird idea that you
know the small nation of north korea
that has not really done anything for
the last you know century is now going
to try to overtake the u.s and why did
they do that because china basically
told the us movie studios to do that um
now the other example
which is interesting i mean if you
remember if you remember when the star
wars
uh uh french the new franchise came out
with the last three movies right uh very
diverse uh you know they have characters
of a lot of different ethnicities they
have a lot karen's characters with a lot
of different skin colors uh to reflect
you know the reality that you know the
u.s has changed and we really value
those things and we want to have those
things in our movies now uh and you know
we're lectured by the movie theaters by
our elites every day that you know we
need to do these things uh that's that's
culture that's the culture that we want
to live in
uh and that's what we're being told by
them all the time
and then
when
they took that movie to china
they actually removed the black
characters they removed uh you know the
diverse characters from from the posters
from everything because you know
china is not on board with that and they
want to make money on china so that's
fine and it's just this gigantic double
standard of what we're being told by our
elites of what we're being told by our
companies in hollywood and beyond about
what you should be told uh
about what you should believe in
and when it comes to china it's just
business as usual i'm just here to make
money right like there was this amazing
they you probably remember this this
amazing uh speech by rick gervais
at the oscars uh
uh again and he was talking to uh tim
cook uh because he was there apple tv
was just launched and he and you know he
basically just said you know
if you get an award today don't you know
just don't be so sanctimonious about how
good you are or how terrible your
country is because realistically you're
just you know operating off slave shops
in china so just take your little reward
and go home
and we need realistically we need more
people to speak up to that because
it's it's it's a really bizarre
situation that we're in
really bizarre what about the supply
chains like we've talked a lot about uh
mobile apps we've talked about some more
psychological stuff uh you have tsmc
which isn't in china it's in taiwan but
there's a risk there that that uh
something could happen
but we have a lot of supply chains in
manufacturing in china itself
what can the united states do to lessen
the dependency is it just reshoring
bring back manufacturing bring back uh
labor opportunities and supply chains to
the u.s are there other opportunities
for us to uh to lessen that dependency
yeah um a couple of things uh
there are two big issues with supply
chains happening today the first one is
you know we actually have a lot of
dependencies on core
uh rare earth minerals things that we
already covered the other thing that's
still happening is even though you know
we're here in miami and
realistically like life is normal after
kovit
for china china has still decided to you
know continue what they call the zero
dynamic zero covet so china is still
having a lot of lockdowns including in
cities that are core industrial cities
for china
so because of that
you effectively have a lot of delays you
have a lot of issues with getting stuff
that were you know manufacturing china
here so those are the two big you know
issues one part of the the supply chain
is getting weaponized the other part is
still suffering from a lot of covert
disruptions
even today
now as for things that we can do
i do believe that this idea of
reassuring american manufacturing
will be a big thing over the last 10 20
years like we absolutely believe in that
excited to invest in companies that are
doing that because we absolutely need
this to happen
um now is it only in america
not necessarily you know i think that
you know
one of the things that america should
think very deeply about about is who are
the allies that will stand by
the united states in this new divide
that we're going to be living in
uh so we should absolutely you know be
sending uh you know more manufacturing
to to mexico to uh you know countries in
latin america that are supportive of the
government
of the us government but you know for
sure we need to rebuild a lot of
infrastructure and manufacturing here in
america how much of the difficulties in
reshoring around supply chains
manufacturing is the cost of labor in
the united states is just astronomically
higher than obviously in china but even
places like mexico and some of our other
allies and so do we have to make a
choice if we want to actually reshore
not move from you know china-based
manufacturing and supply chain maybe to
mexico or somewhere else we actually
want to bring it back within the borders
of the united states uh does this give
rise to robotics and basically says hey
we're going to take the american kind of
blue collar worker and we have to put
them on the sidelines when it comes to
supply chains and manufacturing because
we just can't pay them and still compete
from a cost perspective with some of
these other areas right absolutely you
know we're investors in a company called
hadrian and you know what hittering is
doing uh is effectively rebuilding the
supply chain for the aerospace and
defense industry um and you know there's
a lot of companies that tried to do this
before
and they tried to do this just with
software uh and it's just you know try
just robotics just autonomous machines
and part of the founder's insight is you
actually need both you need machinists
you need people who are extremely good
at this that work better with machines
and i believe that is going to be the
future of a lot of industries too you
know realistically absolutely you're
right that we can't have you know
manufacture everything in america
with the cost of living
in with the you know wages and things
that we have here today it would be
prohibitively expensive however we do
have the room for technology
to not get rid of but partner
with blue collar jobs
um to you know really
rebuild a lot of the things that we need
i think a narrative that we
unfortunately believed in for the last
50 years as is that this idea of college
educated workers are somehow a superior
class to blue collar jobs and i think we
hopefully we might go through a
renaissance where we see you know a lot
of people that are working on really
hard working like really hard-working
people that are working on these jobs to
help rebuild the infrastructure of the
united states i mean there was the
industrial revolution which obviously
laid the foundation for the world that
we know today in the united states and
incredible economic prosperity and
growth uh as a nation um it feels like
there was a shift uh maybe in the 90s to
wall street and then in the 2000s and
early 2010s uh more to silicon valley
but it was all about uh optimizing ad
systems or getting people to click on
things and uh you know i would argue
that facebook is a net positive for the
world and and uh it's not so much like
these things are bad
but it does mean that many of our
smartest
most capable people
were not going and working on these
really hard manufacturing supply chain
kind of industrial
type problems
i think that's changing right i think
you myself and a couple other investors
have spent quite a bit of time uh making
investments in companies you know some
that come to mind immediately or
obviously hadrian varda andero traba
like you can just go down the line
is this the next trend uh that uh will
kind of lead to that renaissance is
basically silicon valley style
entrepreneurs saying i understand how to
build teams i understand how to raise
capital i understand how to solve
problems and think from first principle
standpoint now i'm not going to go do
this in just a pure software kind of
consumer product space i'm instead going
to go to the industrial space and try to
solve problems there
it is our best hope you know i think
there's a lot to be talked about
institutional decay and what has
happened to government what has happened
to our other institutions over the last
20 plus years
but realistically
if we are to fix this
we need the most talented people in the
world to help us fix those problems and
the most talented people in the world
are working in technology today i think
that is a very fair statement and i
think is you probably agree that you
know the most ambitious people they want
to start companies they want to start
you know the next unicorn that kind of
stuff um so we need to find them and we
need to partner with them and we need to
throw all of our weight behind them to
help solve those problems yeah and when
you see that um how much of this is a
psychological or cultural
need to make people understand that this
is important and it's okay to want to
make the united states
kind of this great country that
can continue to lead in manufacturing
and kind of these industrial industries
versus actually solving technology
problems or solving other types of
things like can we just change people's
mindset and then that will uh be eighty
percent of the solution or are there
really hard manufacturing supply chain
you know type problems that need to be
solved and psychology is great but like
we still got to just solve the problems
well you know
i think realistically there are
absolutely you know real problems to be
solved uh in things that you know we may
spend billions of dollars in trying to
solve them and still fail
but
i think that it doesn't change the fact
that throughout history
you just had to do hard things and hope
that something will work so
i don't know how to answer your question
other than say
yes those things are hard they might not
work
but if we don't have the most ambitious
people with the most impressive visions
of the future to spend all of their time
all of the you know blood sweat and
tears on these things
we're not gonna figure it out it's that
that part is very clear
so all i can do is to hope
to
find the best people and try to rally
them
to
help help work on these issues and do
that myself too of course um
because if we don't do that then i don't
think
we can expect anything to be solved so
what's interesting to me is uh the
government in the united states for uh
quite a while
helped to
build a lot of these industries and they
pushed forward
innovation and progress
it feels like we reached an end point of
government programs being able to do
certain things so obviously the the
quintessential example is spacex uh was
able to do something that nasa wasn't
right and uh they're collaborative they
work together but without spacex i don't
think that we are anywhere near where we
are from a space uh kind of innovation
standpoint uh we now see other private
companies starting to push the pace of
innovation and progress and drill
obviously when it comes to defense and
many other examples you had a
conversation with steve blank recently
and he basically was like we need to
re-create or rebuild the department of
defense and i didn't get the sense that
he's like let's just go get trillions of
dollars from the government and hire a
bunch of government employees and like
that's going to be the solution what
were your takeaways from talking to you
know what many people would consider a
great investor a great uh kind of
entrepreneur and coach uh but also a
military veteran in uh steve blank yeah
uh you know i think just the one thing i
want to say about c blank that i think
is really important for people to know
um i think c blank got very famous about
the lean startup which you know a lot of
people tied tied to you know the rise of
consumer apps in the early 2000s
but you know steve blank is someone that
has spent
more time than basically anyone studying
the relationship between silicon valley
and in the defense industry so
if you look back at the history silicon
valley has always had ties to the
department of defense
and you know hopefully we're going
through a renaissance of that now to
answer your question specifically you
know
on what steve thought it must be done
it's it's hard to believe that the
people that are going to fix the issue
are going to be the people that created
the issue
uh and i think you know a lot of what
happens today with government is
we have the same people that have been
there the entire time so
i do think that there is
a massive problem that we have today is
that you know to your point like the the
next elon musk is going to start a
company he's not going to work for nasa
that is a positive thing overall the
world is going to be better off because
of spacex than if he had not done that
but we do need a new generation of
people who are interested in rebuilding
those institutions
uh you know when i look back uh as you
know used to be the sort of libertarian
guy
uh i i there's a ronald reagan quote you
know the the eight most dangerous words
in the english language are i'm from the
government and i'm here to help um
and
you know i used to think that those
things are fun and as i watched the
institutional decay uh happening for the
last 10-15 years you probably remember
this there was a lot of people cheering
for that like right like there was a lot
of people saying the government sucks
you know let's let it fail and we'll
probably be better off because of that i
think sitting here in 2022 it's very
clear that we're not in a better
position right um
so we better have new people we better
have new extremely talented people that
have the ambitions of rebuilding
institutions
we need new companies we do but we also
need competent
highly
highly competent institutions in the
department of defense but also in other
areas of the government that need to be
that they need to be better working with
startups but they have an ambition of
building a great country yeah what's the
role of government in these innovative
fields like should the government be the
one trying to invent new things and uh
kind of commercialize them uh should it
be like a public-private partnership
what have you seen going to be the most
effective uh role for government and you
know there's the modern day environment
and there's kind of history so maybe we
can take some lessons from history and
apply them to today yeah yeah totally
well you know in a lot of in a lot of
industries i do believe that it's true
that government needs to mostly stay out
of the way um
that's probably the answer for you know
the vast majority of industries
but in industries like defense
where the government is the ultimate
buyer of basically every product
the government does need to step up and
show the path for these companies that
are trying to innovate in the industry
to be able to work with them
you know a lot of these companies today
they you know
spend years getting grants from the
government
and you know just trying to build
something but in reality they're never
able to actually get a program of record
and get the government to become the
ultimate buyer
um
so we need like we absolutely do need to
change that and you know we we had a
podcast recently with uh pete newell
that he goes very deep deep on you know
how do these sbir sttr programs work
what do we need to do to reshape them
because realistically
startups today
if they're working on these really hard
problems and the government is the
ultimate buyer
they absolutely need to be able to you
know
get a path from the government if you do
these things and if you actually execute
we're willing to buy this
um
and that maze is way too complicated and
i think it is the government's role to
be able to fix a lot of those issues
when we think about that government role
how much of the problems we're facing
are rooted in a lack of math science and
engineering education in the united
states maybe compared to other countries
like if we just beefed up
kind of the way that we trained people
and we got more math science and
engineering uh graduates or people who
were interested in these fields would
that permeate all of society both public
and private market we would just kind of
have a better educated workforce that
then could go work on these problems
well i think to be clear i think from uh
startups would definitely benefit from
that new companies would definitely
benefit for that from that
and absolutely i think we would have a
lot more you know potentially great tech
companies great tech companies working
in the defense industry if we had more
engineers but i think a lot of problems
with government and how it works with
startups today are due to incentives
more than anything else
so
realistically
you know what we need is not necessarily
people to you know be smarter than they
already already were is to realize that
the set of incentives that we have in
place are leading us to a path
that may not be great for the country
overall that may what are the incentives
well realistically uh you know the us
government works mostly with defense
industries um
in the defense industries work mostly
with the big companies the primes um
and you know they are the ones that have
the power to lobby they have the power
to you know know the right people get
the right people to do things for them
inside of the government um and it's
really hard it's impossibly hard for a
startup to break in
uh and the reality is you know when you
have a set budget uh
these become very zero-sum games
uh and you know when you have you know
the five primes fighting for for a
certain budget and then you start
startup wants to come in the system is
designed for the startup to fail right
um now what happens is if we do need
innovation and if we do believe that
innovation is the only way that we're
going to get out of this thing
out of the situation that we're in
we do need the government the government
to understand
that you know
the breakthrough innovations are going
to come from these startups and we need
to nurture them and we need to help to
help them succeed
when we see that um why is anderl been
able to break through to some degree i
know that one of their aspirations is to
become the next great you know prime
contractor in the defense industry why
are they able to break through as a
startup where maybe others are failing
or designed to fail well i mean to be
clear um it's probably one of the most
incredible teams that came out of
silicon valley and i see they're based
in l.a but you know i see silicon valley
broadly in the last 20 years right like
if you look at the founding team of that
company you have an incredible
visionaire and technologist you have you
know people who know
the vc industry extremely well but also
people that came from the government
right like a lot of that team
that came from working with the
government so a lot of that team came uh
from volunteer and volunteer had to sue
the government at some point to actually
be able to succeed um
so i think it was a combination of the
right team at the right point in time uh
at a point that america and you know
people here investors were seeing the
problems that we had from a geopolitical
standpoint and saw that we needed a
company like andrew
to
you know start the wave of new companies
uh building in the defense industry why
did palantir pursue the government i
don't think a lot of people know that
story yeah and i i don't claim to know
the details i would have to look it up
but ultimately you know
and spacex did the same thing by the way
uh so the way that you know because of
the way that government procurement
processes work uh the government makes
very clear like you have to bid uh for
this project uh
at you know certain amounts that given
timeline
and you know they were able to prove
that you know even though they were able
to meet those things
uh ultimately the government still went
with you know with the old way of doing
things with the traditional primes with
the traditional contractors so
um like i said it's a system that is
designed for these new companies to fail
um and we need a new generation of you
know officers that are able to recognize
that we need those new companies to
succeed and that we're all going to be
better off for it yeah it's it's
fascinating to kind of see um in many
ways
the silicon valley technologists who
for years have been labeled as uh not
wanting to follow the rules not wanting
to
kind of adhere to the old way of doing
things move fast break things like all
these kind of anecdotes
actually when it comes to the palantirs
the andrills uh the spacex's many of
them they work directly with the
government and what they're actually
asking for is enforcement of the rules
and frameworks uh because they believe
they have an advantage and they see that
maybe those rules and frameworks aren't
being applied equally uh across the
industry and so it runs counter to i
think what the mainstream narrative of
like oh these people just want to break
the rules now to be clear there are
plenty of companies you can uber airbnb
and others who show up and they say hey
we're gonna break the rules because we
don't think the rules are right and
we're gonna lobby and try to get them
changed or whatever uh but it goes back
to like the world's not black and white
right that there's kind of a full flavor
uh across the industry of people who
want to work within the rules and then
some people believe that you know
breaking the rules is important i i
agree with you um you know i think the
nuance for me is that at the end of the
day um i still believe that the future
and all the innovation is created by
rebels
however i think what we need to
recognize is that in the world that
we're living in
not accepting the institutional decay
that we've been living through
and trying to build a great company to
go reinvent the defense industry
reinvent aerospace is in and of itself
an act of rebellion
now you may not be able to move and move
fast and break things in those
industries and i don't think a lot of
people have
but you know we should absolutely be
inspired by
you know the
the fact that so many of these
individuals so many of these founders
were decided to go against
all the forces against everything in the
status quo to try to build those great
companies yeah what are other industries
outside of just defense that you see
kind of this institutional decline and
you now believe that startups or kind of
private enterprises uh will be a key
ingredient to helping uh rejuvenate them
yeah i mean look i i don't have as much
depth on it but i i think healthcare for
sure uh is a is a big one i mean
construction real estate all of these
areas um i mean if you look at
healthcare healthcare is what like a
fourth of the us gdp a fifth uh it keeps
growing never we never know how it's
gonna stop like maybe 2050 is going to
be half um
so
absolutely like the the u.s health
healthcare system is only on its way to
bankruptcy um this is very clear so
if companies don't fix that now if if
institutions don't fix that now um
it's going to get pretty ugly yeah and
then what about the role of venture
capital right we talk about the role of
government we talk about the role of
private enterprise but most of these
startups are being funded by venture
capital uh it seems
ten years ago it was not popular to go
fund many of uh these types of companies
that were now trying to rejuvenate
institutions palantir maybe was one of
the first ones where
peter thiel and a number of others said
hey this is important work and we're
going to go do this
there's a little bit bigger of a group
of investors who are willing to do it
but still not a massive number
what do you see as like the financiers
role in in this entire movement yeah you
know i think there's enough answer to
this um
realistically
at the end of the day
one could say that the role of investors
is just to make money um
but i would say more importantly
there
when when people make that argument a
lot of what they try to say is
hey we don't know where the next
breakthrough is gonna come from like
realistically
it's so random in venture capital like
when you're looking at those startups at
day zero everything is so random that
you don't really know
like
what what is what can really have the
power to change the world
um i believe in that
what i also believe in is that at the
end of the day
you need to be working something that
matters you need to be working something
important
and you don't know if that's going to be
what's going to change the world
but
there's a shot and as a venture
capitalist you're betting on the shot
you know that you know
nine out of 10 cases is going to fail
but when it succeeds it's going to get
really big
but if you don't have the conviction as
a founder or as an investor that you're
working on something truly important to
be to begin with
then i i really have questions right
it's not going to be the next fart app
that's going to really change things
right um so
i do think that there is a role for
working on things that matter and i
think that investors do have a
responsibility there yeah what's
fascinating about this is uh early on
it's betting on people and we've seen
over and over again uh some of these
companies are built by people who have
industry experience but more often than
not they actually don't have any
experience in this specific industry
right if you take uh palmer lucky uh and
kind of his entire team at andrew they
didn't have a ton of experience in the
defense sector now some of the people
from palantir obviously they had worked
there uh uh previously but when you're
evaluating these teams like what are
some of the themes that you've seen uh
or kind of uh traits that you're able to
pull out and uh kind of recognize uh in
a pattern that you're like yeah these
people have a higher probability it
doesn't guarantee success but they have
a higher probability of succeeding
versus maybe other teams that you all
evaluate well i i think i think you need
a secret right uh and i think a question
that i always ask is
what do you understand about the world
that nobody else has realized in some
ways
and it's sort of a cliche venture
capital but
you you talk to these people and it just
seems that they're living in the future
they they see all the problems in the
present um
they see a potential for a future world
and the people around them have just not
realized that yet
um on your point on your point about
andrew uh i mean you have an absolutely
visionary founder that your point did
not have a lot of experience in defense
but had a team that actually did that
really know the ins and outs in and out
of it so that was a complete team right
and i think in a lot of these really
complicated industries really regulated
industries when you actually have a
complete team that is able one like has
a visionaire that is living in the
future
but two
has compliments to that person
that really understand like how the
system works not to necessarily always
play by the rules
but to know how to to know how and when
to break them if necessary
is really important yeah and then what
about some of these folks who come from
i'll call it silicon valley more as an
idea rather than the physical
geography but we're now seeing more of
those individuals uh go into politics or
go into i mean positions of influence
that aren't just running companies like
how important is that or what are you
seeing there
well you know i think this goes back to
to what i was talking about we need new
people to rejuvenate the government to
change a lot of these institutions um i
welcome that i hope um i hope more of
this happens i mean let's go back 200
years right like the founding fathers a
lot of the founding fathers believed
that everybody should serve in public
service at one point in their lives
right up until nixon every every man in
america was expected to serve the middle
to to serve the military right
um
and now we don't have any of that
anymore i'm not advocating that you know
we should be leaving
should be living in in the world that we
that we lived in
but i do think that there is a role for
serving a higher interest than than than
yourself yeah um so i you know i think
it's amazing i think it's amazing that
we're seeing so many of these people run
for office ideally we're going to be
seeing more people working with the
government working to rebuild our
institutions and you know that that's
that if we're going to solve those
issues
this is part of the process yeah you
recently moved to florida uh
congratulations uh and i've heard you
say that the future of america looks
very similar to florida which will put
many people
their heads will spin when they hear
that what do you mean by that well look
um over the last two years um you know
my girlfriend and i basically traveled
we did a nomadic thing that a lot of
people did we traveled over 25 states
you know like saw over 40 states um
and it's very clear to me
that
you know
in florida people are the happiest
people i've ever seen in the us like by
far
and if you don't believe me just come
just come here
and you know you walk around and it's in
people's faces um
you know you walk around in california
and you're trying to not step in human
poo
right
um
people here don't really accept that
we refuse to think that's normal um and
you know ultimately
it is the the one city the one state in
america
that when you talk to people
they still believe
for one that the u.s is a good thing
right which 20 years ago nobody would
disagree with that that the u.s is a
positive force force in the world but
they also believe that there is a hope
for a future in america that is brighter
than what we have today
um
and it's
it's probably there are probably other
places in america that that also believe
in that
but
people here really take pride in that
how much of that is because uh there's
such a deep uh seated kind of
immigration uh and it's a melting pot of
people from you know a lot of central
and south american countries uh but also
other you know countries around the
world do you need uh kind of that um
diversity of origin in order to continue
to have that ideal uh be persistently
put on a pedestal and say hey you know i
came to america and so i believe in the
ideas of the american dream or is it
something else
um you know i'm i'm an immigrant so i i
recognize the the role for you know
america being the shining north star
that everybody that everybody aspires to
um i think there's something to that
but
i think
if we are to you know take this counter
back to what it was
we need to put the responsibility not
just you know on immigrants i think
america could america is a great place
but on the shoulders of every single
person in this country to say
this is a great country this country has
great values this country has a great
culture american culture actually stands
for something um
and you know that's on everybody so i
when i look at florida i i you know i
think there's a lot of you know like
cuban immigrants latin american
immigrants that came here that knew what
socialism was um
and sure that's part of it too but i
think the average person here just takes
pride in america being what it is so
you're unique you're from brazil but
you're here in america and if somebody
listened to the first half of this
conversation they would say like man
this
guy is very very america first uh almost
as if you were born here
why is it that you're from another
country but you believe so deeply in
america uh and you're not living in
brazil and saying hey you know brazil
should be the leading country in the
world uh and we need to go do all these
things to make that happen yeah well i
mean look if you look at the history of
latin america it just basically swings
back and forth and it you know we have
there's a saying in brazil that brazil
is going to be the country brazil is a
counter of the future and it will always
be because you know there's always great
promises of you know
the latin american countries becoming
great countries and at some point they
get taken over by the communist party of
their countries and they go back to
being shitty i mean just look at what's
happening in argentina now i i like i
don't remember the exact numbers i i saw
yesterday the government of argentina
just raised the interest rates to 69.5
percent uh because they're having
inflation rates i think in the three
digits now right um and if you look at
the history of latin america that's
always what it was um
so you know i i came here because i do
believe that america is the shiny north
star i i do believe that american values
do stand for something um and i think
that you know the promise of the
american dream that you can work hard
and you will succeed um is really
important um
and even in the times of you know
institutional decay i'll say you know
it's it's really it's really flashy
especially in tech and as a vc to say
that you're very optimistic um about the
future and you're very optimistic about
america in the west
to be completely transparent i'm not
that optimistic uh i i think we have
some deep rooted issues uh i think
there's very good reasons to be
pessimistic
but
if we're gonna go down like we better go
down like kicking and screaming and
fighting with everything that we have
you know like realistically like america
is the only hope for the west uh
if if america doesn't stand up if
america doesn't solve its issues
i don't believe that there is any
there's any other country there's any
other nation that will have the power
to you know
prevent the world from you know living
in a communist dictatorship and
everybody's speaking mandarin in 20
years from now
do you think that's a possible risk oh
yeah it's absolutely a possible risk uh
like
we have a like we have a country that is
run by communist dictators um that have
a very clear plan
to becoming the you know one superpower
of the world um
at some point that conflicts with
american ideas that conflicts uh with
america as as being the power that it
has been for the last 50 years so
do i believe that you know us and china
will engage in a hot war not necessarily
i think i think i think the possibility
is certainly there
but
realistically
we have to recognize that
you know american ideals or you know the
ideas that people who used to have 50
years ago
clash completely with the view of the
world that china has
and you know
something very interesting and i watch
this
is that you know i've observed this uh
in the last few decades is
you know
it usually it used to be
that thinking that you know cultures can
be better or worse in certain ways was
not a controversial thing
right like
you you look at history and
realistically
when you study history all that it is
it's a lot of people trying to recognize
things from previous cultures that they
wanted to take with them and things from
previous cultures that they wanted to
reject right when people are studying
the greeks and the romans and the
renaissance that that's that's all it is
um
and for some reason now we're not
allowed to say
that the values that the chinese
communist party stands for are horrific
we don't want that for ourselves and we
will stand up for what we believe in and
that we actually think that our culture
is good why aren't we allowed to say
that
well because we've had a lot of you know
in the last
ever ever since the early 2000s and
since before then uh we've had a lot of
the elites a lot of the leadership in
this country to say oh you you know you
can't say that china is bad in some ways
that's racist uh you can't say that you
know america is good because you know
that's right privilege um
and we started regulating um what people
are allowed to say what people are
allowed to think uh and then with the
rise of social media um those problems
all began became significantly magnified
so this is a really interesting point
that i think is becoming more obvious uh
in the last two and a half years somehow
we condemned either implicitly or
explicitly
individuals who questioned mainstream
narratives and you can go through public
health crisis the solution
uh inflation you know just down the line
but those people are having the last
laugh and uh the one that just i think
is hitting people over the head is uh
within the last couple of days the cdc
came out and issued new guidance around
the virus on the vaccine and they're now
saying that if you test positive you
don't have to quarantine
and they're saying that uh people who
are vaccinated and unvaccinated should
be treated the same
they're also saying things like if a
child contracts uh
covet 19 they don't have to skip a day
of school
and so if you had said that
two weeks ago
you would have been condemned publicly
privately uh and quite literally you
could potentially lose your job and many
other uh pieces of of blowback uh well i
mean here is one right so crazy this
morning i think i saw this this morning
on the way over here denmark just banned
kovin 19 vaccines and children
are they all trump is now like are they
all trump supporters now or are we still
not allowed to have that conversation
why is it that we can't have the
conversation like in in the united
states there's 100
uh a line that gets drawn
uh that appears to be moving but there's
a line
this is allowed to be talked about this
is not allowed to be talked about
well um
there's a person who has documented this
better than anybody um martin garry
right that wrote the revolt of the
public um
and in in a lot of ways
the elites that we have today
know that their days are counted um you
know with the rise of social media
in the fact that everybody now has a
microphone that they can speak to
um
these people
have
completely lost their minds in a lot of
ways uh trying to save themselves
from the fact that you know elites are
not as powerful as they used to be right
it used to be 20 years ago that you know
the new york times was the people of
record and you just watched cnn
and you had a view of the world because
the elites told you what that what was
true or not
now you can't do that anymore right like
you have independent journalists you
have uh twitter
disproving things that the government
said was true you know like a few hours
ago so
because of that you know we're
definitely living
it ever since 2016
a very deep reactionary moment that
these elites
are not okay with seeing their power
fading away um
and with you know the institutional
decay that's happening right so like
people don't care about what the cdc
thinks anymore right so the cdc is it
has been in this weird position of
okay um
do we lie to savor to save face do we
lie because that would make us more
credible or you know do we go back on
our word of like two weeks ago um and
some of this is malicious for sure but
some of this is also the fact that you
know
it turns out that you know
in those positions you're dealing with
incomplete information all the time you
don't know what's true
and things are going to change um and we
don't have a generation of leaders
that really
know how to live in this new digital
world in this new world of twitter and
social media
and they're still stuck to their old
ways
would these people be better off if they
just came out let's take the federal
reserve as one example maybe the cdc is
another uh during the public health
crisis that the cdc just came out and
said hey
there's a lot of stuff a lot of moving
parts
we don't know yet
here's the things that we're doing to
try to get a better handle on what's
happening here's things that we're
trying to do to get a better handle on
what you should be doing we'll come back
to you with more information when we
have it
and
in the federal reserve's case coming out
and saying hey
we had to step in we mitigated
short-term pain it's likely that we're
going to get some high inflation make
sure that you're prepared by the way
we're going to do everything we can to
keep it under control we'll keep you
updated as we go like is that the better
strategy in today's digital age of
communication from the institutions to
the people or is it better to do what
both of those organizations did and
again are they being ignorant or are
they being malicious up for debate uh
but they definitely said something that
was provably wrong uh and it doesn't
feel uh whether right or wrong it
doesn't feel like they were actually
being transparent about what their
current thoughts were yeah i mean i i do
want to be clear that
i do believe that you know what you see
what the cdc has done and the degree to
which we've been lied to is inexcusable
um so whatever they tried to do
was you know borderline criminal in a
lot of ways
however like in the future
um i do think that there is a role
for you know doing what you're saying
admitting
simply because the alternative is not
possible anymore
you know the idea that you're going to
say something and the world's going to
change and the world's not going to hear
about it
because of social media because of all
of these things it's not realistic like
people have access to information people
are going to look at twitter people are
going to read substack
so
you can't control everything unless you
want to be china right
so if we're not going to do that then
you absolutely need a new generation of
leaders that acknowledges the world that
we live in today
i think if during the early days of the
virus if somebody had stood up and said
i don't know
two questions said i don't know that
answer right we're working on it i don't
know i don't know i don't know i think
people would trust them way more oh for
sure right for sure but for some reason
uh it's like an egotistical or an
arrogant uh belief of the world that you
can't say that because if you say it for
some reason you think that you lose
credibility you lose kind of the elite
status uh but the internet if there's
anything that we've seen uh it's the
opposite and actually by presenting kind
of the arrogant elitist view of the
world
you lose all credibility and
you know is there an institution now
where the american people have the
utmost trust i mean if you go through
all of these institutions
the presidential administration
i mean we had pretty much two different
ends of the spectrum over the last you
know call it six years eight years
whatever it is uh
fifty percent of the country doesn't
agree right if not more i think right
now the president's uh approval rating
is down below forty percent or at forty
percent not good uh if you look at all
the economic situations i mean there's a
meme of the federal reserve chairman
just you know using a money printer like
for in some ways like that epitomizes
just the public's view of this
you can look at all of the public health
stuff and then you can even look at some
of the law enforcement agencies like one
of the craziest things to me is when you
look at from a extremist standpoint you
had one side of the aisle screaming
defund the police and now you have
another side of the aisle screaming like
defund the fbi
yeah right and so it's
there's almost no institution that is
safe from the internet and the internet
is kind of coming for all of them one by
one
yeah no it it it absolutely is uh you
know i think
that's a lot of what martin gury talks
about um and i do think that the the
scary fact is
that
we don't know we don't necessarily know
how to rebuild them that answer is
definitely not clear yet
um
the internet is in a lot of ways
this thing that breaks every institution
but is not very good at rebuilding it
and that that will be that would
definitely be the the major challenge um
of the next 10 20 years i mean aside
from the geopolitical stuff i think from
an internal perspective
um
it is possible and i'm not saying i
believe this but it is possible that
we're going to be sitting you know 30
years from now and say like hey
was the social media thing like actually
good overall like did it make it better
or worse and we may not like uh what we
see
there was a uh an employee recently at
twitter uh who's no longer at the
company
who was found guilty of spying
for saudi arabia and
the details aren't necessarily super
super important as much as the idea that
a country
has
an individual working at
a social media company
is another kind of um you know aspect of
this battle that we've been talking
about where if china has mobile apps on
our phones and they can control what the
algorithm says that's i think most
people agree probably not the greatest
thing
but then also like what about the
employees that work at some of these
organizations like how do you think
through
uh that situation well um
i mean
i'm glad that it finally came out that
that twitter has uh you know some people
from
working there to favor
saudi arabia but you know foreign
intelligence uh
you know trying to spy on startups
is by far like
like it's it's an extremely prevalent
thing in silicon valley and i use
silicon valley broadly i mean think
about it this way right like if you are
a foreign intelligence gov you know a
foreign intelligence agency working for
government like saudi arabia or china
um
why would you not
try to spend some money
to
get information or get you know agents
working
in tech or in silicon valley
tech is a shiny thing on the hill
that a lot of people aspire to as you
know
uh it's extremely unstructured
it's very decentralized in some ways
so much of it is based on trust so much
of it is interpersonal
so you know getting people inside of
those companies it's not that hard
but are these large tech companies like
the googles the facebooks of the world
uh or is the concern more about them
getting into companies like uh palantir
and drill spacex that have uh a national
defense bent right so it's all of the
above you think it's all oh yeah it's
all of them and and once these
individuals are inside of these
organizations and i don't think you or i
have an opinion as to you know is it one
individual at all of google or is it you
know five percent of the workforce
let's shy hopefully we'll cross our
fingers and hope it's on the smaller end
um
is it just passing of information is it
actively working against the company
like what is the risk uh that people
are worried about in terms of if these
individuals get hired at the business
how combative is it versus more as an
information gathering exercise oh um and
this is where i may get accused of being
crazy conspiratorial but i i 100 believe
that there are people inside of twitter
that are trying to suppress content that
is
you know not in the interest of the ccp
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new 8 sleep pod 3 you can sleep as
cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot
as 110 degrees fahrenheit that's the
secret of thermoregulation better sleep
better energy get yourself innate sleep
you can go to eightsleep.com pomp today
to go ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep i i believe that fully and i've
i've sort of seen it happen uh you know
i have a lot of friends i have a lot of
people who are you know deep in national
security that have told me
that you know
you just look at the numbers right like
okay like you know this like you have
like a million over a million followers
on twitter you kind of know what to
expect when you when you say a post like
there are certain words and china is one
of them yeah that on pretty much every
platform we have if you say it and you
put in the title or you do whatever uh
somehow it's just not that popular
yeah i mean really weird right like you
know like you can say
hello good morning and you're gonna get
a thousand likes and or you can post
some things that are you know what versa
to venezuela or brazil and you're still
gonna get some likes but you say the
word china and there's nothing
and you think that that is likely again
we don't know for sure but likely uh
intentional
i i i i don't
i struggle to see what are the other
options how do we solve the problem or
how do we evaluate that threat is it
just hope that our national defense uh
capabilities and national intelligence
organizations are able to to figure that
stuff out as it appears uh someone along
the way was able to figure out this uh
this employee that was uh helping saudi
arabia at twitter or is it
something else well i mean part of it is
that we need to cross our fingers and
knock the table that elon ends up buying
twitter against against his will
at this point
so
you know i i do think that having an
individual like that
is
necessary
to
you know
to solving this but you know pom to be
completely honest like i think what we
need to do is to fight back you know
like i think
and this is part of the culture that
doesn't let us say things uh that we've
seen happen uh more recently but you
know i still come back to this and and i
think
the example of like the soviet union or
gm in in in the 40s
these people would not
like if those people were here today and
they saw what's happening with you know
companies lobbying to you know build
chip manufacturing in china that kind of
stuff that is so anti is it it goes so
against the interest of of the united
states
you know these prior generations would
not hesitate to call those people
traders
right why are we so afraid to speak up
like when we look at you know the
example of twitter that you know there
are people inside of twitter that may be
favoring interests that run against the
interests of the united states
like
why are we afraid to call that out for
what it is
and say that people
in twitter
are you know
doing something that could be treasonous
to do us right and who has the courage
to investigate that right we need more
of it which by the way like is partially
why i'm bullish in florida it's
partially why uh i i see a lot of what's
happening here and i think is
encouraging
florida is the one state in the nation
that we've seen the interest in fighting
back
100
it feels also like uh the rest of the
country or many places in the country
look at it and they say uh that's insane
that's extreme that is whatever uh but i
think people who live here are saying
no that is exactly what you would expect
from somebody who has a very specific
vision of the future and if you disagree
with that vision of the future obviously
you're not gonna like what they do but
they're saying it's worth fighting for
and and they're going for it and i think
um you know we've talked a lot about the
social media platforms but there's
companies like disney which those are
the ones that absolutely blow my mind
right where uh disney now has more
subscribers than netflix right from a
size standpoint obviously disney has
incredible intellectual property it has
the physical um amusement parks all
these different things uh
but it is insane i mean if you look at
some of the things and look we can talk
about the geopolitical conflict and
adversaries and all that
it's one component but also just some of
the information you know i have an
eight-month-old daughter and uh there's
been multiple times where we've turned
on some cartoon
and i look at my wife and i'm like shut
this off this is insane you know pomp we
went from a world where you know the
mainstream american left went from you
know
fighting wars in the middle east is bad
let's stand for peace and let's stand
for
equality
to a world in which we're now having a
very serious argument about
whether or not
teaching
gender ideology to five-year-olds is a
good thing
right like that is the word that we're
living in now
uh and people just went crazy and
coveted magnified all of that but but
realistically this has been
the case for you know
10 20 years at this point i do think um
and people hate when i say this but uh i
i fundamentally believe it we need to
bring back the right to offend people
yes we have we have somehow uh condemned
if you offend anyone regardless of if
you're right or not you're wrong
and what i think ends up happening is
like there is a right and wrong
in many facets right if you ask somebody
stealing if you literally go to some
cities in america and you say uh this
person stole something there are some
people who will say well why did they
steal it did they do they absolutely
have to do it then that's okay
all right and you say yourself
hold on a second here right like
something that should be like hardline
in the sand
there's right there's wrong these are
the rules for us to have a functioning
society where people feel safe and feel
like uh uh the future is better than it
the past
you can't steal
but as we've seen san francisco being
one of those places and it doesn't feel
that way and you know and david sacks
has has done a great job of this but
realistically like this is why
basically you see every single different
ethnicity now leaving the democratic
party right like like we talked a little
bit about latin america
we see this happening a lot now that you
see that you know hispanics
now uh disapprove president biden more
than white more than white people do is
by far the number one category so we're
definitely going to see
a whole new wave
of different ethnicities that reject
american progressivism
realistically when you took it
when you look at everything that has
been done in the last 50 years with
olinsky and all of those things in the
way that you know we've communicated
things to people the way that we you
know got new generations to believe that
america was bad and that you know you're
a bad person because you're white
and all those kind of things it turns
out that like if you're hispanic you
don't give a [ __ ] about that
right like you you still like your
culture is mostly conservative you're
not going to approve your children being
taught sex at school with like
five-year-olds um and you're gonna
reject crime
right so like
we're going to see that you know
a return to sanity in some ways because
what we have right now is not
sustainable what's the the [ __ ]
insanity of society definitely comes
from a position of privilege right like
if you look around the world the
countries where uh they have the most
stress uh the most uh conflict uh they
have many of the issues uh where people
are worried about safety food all that
type of stuff
none of this should exist yeah i mean so
many so many of these problems they are
just luxury problems yes right 100
if you have the ability uh to spend that
much time
thinking about and doing some of these
things uh
it's just yeah
life's pretty good for you right and i
think part again
um i also think a lot about uh
when you're evaluating founders and
startup teams one of the big questions
is you know do they know some secret or
are they able to to
uh um kind of figure out how to attract
talent all stuff but also just like will
these people not quit right can they
just weather the storm this [ __ ] is
going to be hard they're working on a
hard problem it's going to be a long
period of time will they just not quit
and when you extrapolate that out to
society i do wonder in certain areas uh
geographically what percentage of people
have lived through quote unquote tough
times and that can incorporate all kinds
of different things right there are
people who immigrated to the country
there's people who have experienced
economic hardship there are people who
maybe it's just they got bullied at
school right i mean there's all kinds of
ways to evaluate kind of tough times but
i do think that because the united
states and the economic prosperity that
we've had and uh kind of the i don't
know infiltration of some of these
socialist ideas uh and also just the
softening of the country
there's a higher and higher percentage
of people never done anything hard yeah
i mean so one of my favorite quotes of
all times is uh jeff kennedy uh we
choose to go to the moon not because
it's easy but because it is hard
right
and realistically
people today have become soft now
people have become soft and this this is
where
it it it's it's a real paradox in some
ways
people have become soft because we
actually have some of the greatest times
in history right like we have we have
had for the last seven years we have had
an amazing economy we have had
unprecedented growth rate poverty at an
all-time low um so in some ways the
world is amazing but because we have
gotten rid of all of those ideas all of
those values
um
we we're not allowed really uh well we
don't have a generation that that really
strives for anything right
by the way we haven't really got gotten
into this but you know with the decay of
institutions with the care of religion
and all of these things right um all of
the conversations that we have about
society today
ends up ends up becoming a a
conversation about whether something
should be legal or not right like
we we have a conversation
pick every issue that it is and it can
be guns right gun rights or whatever it
is um and it becomes a hard line of like
hey should this
should this be legal or not legal
in reality we don't have conversations
anymore about virtues and values
right like
there is no conversation about this is
who we are this is the culture that we
live in this is what this is what is
acceptable or not acceptable
um and you know in a weird way that is
what liberalism has devolved into
um and we we need to bring back the idea
of morals we need to bring back the idea
of virtues
i would take this even a step further i
think that there's a
a conversation around ethics and morals
i was uh recently talking
to someone about this idea that um it's
being weaponized in a way that i don't
think most of us uh originally agreed to
or originally sought it so for example
uh in science there are certain things
that people say hey there may be some
benefit for uh us to explore experiment
or even potentially get breakthroughs in
x
and then there will be people who show
up and say well i am a
biology uh
ethicist right you say what the hell is
that
and then they say that is unethical
and so it's almost in some way not only
do we not have the direction and kind of
moral compass of what we do stand for
it's been flipped on its head and now it
is
used as a weapon to argue against
certain things because it is unethical
and when you ask them and what i've said
previously is like morals are important
but when you start getting into this
ethics conversation and it's just
everything is unethical
you have to start to ask yourself well
like what is the framework in which we
determine what our morals are right and
again you go back to stealing lying
cheating these things that i think most
of humanity any culture in any society
they agree like these are not good
things right we do not want to stand for
those things
but then when you move to a sector like
science and i think actually in uh
silicon valley we we saw this there was
a lot of people who argued it was
unethical to invest in defense startups
because it led to a b or c think and
comp and uh investors would opt out and
say our lps do not want us investing in
this it's unethical
and then you turn around you're like
that's stupid
because again it goes back to you're
using an attack that isn't actually
rooted in an understanding of like what
is the moral compass what is the things
that we actually need and uh another
example of this is uh around energy
and the whole esg movement and you know
if you look at a country like germany
like they fell you know hook line and
sinker for the oh it's unethical oh it's
you know it's not good
and now they're basically begging
for oil
yep and it's just you know i i don't
know i don't know if it can be reversed
because i think that it's become so deep
seeded but but we should try well you
know this is where and typically i
haven't given much thought to this but
you know it's funny to me that a lot of
people keep saying oh we need a new
renaissance we need a new renaissance uh
and i was like you know maybe we need a
new counter reformation you know we what
we need to do is
we've had a generation of people
trying to convince us that america was
bad and that we should reject american
ideals and that culture here sucks um in
that you know the world is about to end
because of climate change
and what we need to do is say
hey
we've made some mistakes uh you know
there are things in the past that we
actually need to improve on
but we need to bring back
the ideals and values that we had before
right uh that that's that's a parallel
with the catholic church with the
catholic church um
and i mean you use the examples of like
people in silicon valley like freaking
out about investing in anderl uh you
know like people in germany all that
kind of stuff and the reality is like
what do those people believe in like
what do they stand for right and when
you look at it it's it's not that much
uh i the the core ideal right like we've
heard this word so much more than we had
uh
many years ago uh
equity right like the idea of equity
and in some ways like if you look at
american history right like the american
history inspired by classic liberalism
uh by you know enlightenment ideals
mostly influenced by british culture
right
and there's actually a side of the
enlightenment that was pretty bad right
like if you look at uh you know the
french revolution and like people
talking about bloods of uh rivers of
blood coming down coming down the
streets um
and you know
friends talked a lot about liberty but
france also talked about equality and
fraternity and and if you go back to the
to these philosophers they have a very
different idea of liberty than you know
the british ones did and the american
americans once did and in some ways like
i always think about the word liberalism
because liberalism in america means
something very different than than
liberalism in the rest of the world
means in the rest of the world explain
the difference yeah in the rest of the
world liberalism still means classical
liberalism so when you use the word in
in brazil when you use the word in in
europe people think they were just
talking about free markets uh you know
individual rights that kind of stuff and
liberalism in in america today is a word
that the left has taken over
and realistically the world that we're
living in is a world of liberalism but
it's a world of liberalism that
that essentially
prizes the values
of equality and equity and fraternity
much more than the actual individual
rights and individual freedom
that america was founded upon right
and that's how you end up that's how you
end up with you know
certain things about biology being bad
because people don't like the results
and therefore it's unethical
right
it's how you end up with you know not
investing the company in the companies
that are going to stand up for your
country because you know you think your
country is a bad thing
so those people never seem to move out
of the country by the way yeah no no
never right like we we could we could
make a program to fly them to caracas
one-way ticket for free and they would
never take it right
it's surprising right
well you know they have family they come
up with a bunch of reasons as to why
maybe that's not a great idea i i do
think it's interesting uh have you
looked at all this to uh uh governor
abbott in texas is taking migrants
putting them on buses oh yeah and
bussing them to new york and washington
dc by the way so i i love to talk about
this because it's it's uh it's really
interesting to me as an immigrant right
like talk about ways that we've
perverted american culture um
and this is you know when you asked me
about the immigrant question i was like
you know like there's something about me
being an immigrant that sure revitalizes
the idea of the american dream but i
actually think american people need to
stand up for their own um
you know ultimately
the the debate around immigration in
america is just so weird and it's just
so weaponized intentionally so you know
you go to any other country on earth and
they're not having a debate about
illegal illegal immigration right
that is just such an insane idea that we
actually have a dominant political party
in the united states that actually tries
to defend like illegal immigration right
and like the first word there's pretty
important yeah exactly right like well
so like to me is it like
by the way blake masters got in a lot of
heat for saying this like what is the
right number of illegal like let's have
a debate a debate about legal illegal
immigration what is the right number of
legal immigrants that should be allowed
to in america it's like zero like like
why is that controversial right like i
had to come here i had to follow a
process my family came here they had to
follow a process right like it's so
funny because i talked about this with
my immigrant friends and the idea of
illegal immigration is almost insulting
right like do you know all the pain and
process and money that we have to spend
to come here and i understand like not
all the people may have the access to
these things to come and you know maybe
there are there should be government
programs to to allow people to come here
even you know if they if they don't have
the the ability to pay for some things
we could have that conversation but i
think the starting point is
illegal immigration is not good simply
because we have institutions we have
laws you know and if the act that people
come here the first their first act is
you know
moving breaking those laws then
you know that is actually not good for
our institutions that is not good for
the system that we believe in right so
like what greg abbott did is actually
like hilarious right like
it's so funny because we have all of
these people saying actually we should
allow you know illegal immigrants here
and he's saying no we shouldn't
and then he said okay like you want some
i was i'll send them over to you and
then they see all the issues that come
up with and they're like oh my god
they want to send them back
they're literally saying we're going to
send them back we don't want them right
right and like listen like i'm saying
this as an immigrant like i think it is
important for for a counter to have an
immigration system that serves the
interests of the country and we can have
a debate about what that is right like
it is fair to have the debate but the
idea that like
you can just take in anybody
is a pretty insane idea right
you're proving a theory that i have
after um talking almost
all of my close friends are immigrants
um not intentionally just for whatever
reason uh that's the situation i've
ended up in life uh very happy with it
um
but the people who came here legally
they're more pissed about the illegal
immigration than americans are well it's
because like you're making us
your political tool right like we should
not be having this debate you know why
like the immigration system is not
something hard to fix the reason why
people are having that debate is because
they can get elected on those things let
me take some a different example voter
id
right
that is an insane thing to me coming
from you know a different place
thinking that america actually has an
issue with that because the reality is
it doesn't right like it's very easy to
fix in any country in the world that you
go to the idea that you have to show
your id so you can vote is not a
controversial thing um
but the fact that you can actually fight
against that here you know use some
really spicy words to call people to
call your opponents of if they don't
agree with you and then get elected on
that so that they then you do nothing
and get elected on that again for years
is the fact that is effectively what has
happened with voter id immigration and
all of those issues it's like part of it
is the fact that we can have the
conversation is the beauty of america
but also the fact that we need to have
the conversation is the stupidity of
america yeah you know churchill has this
quote uh which is a pretty funny one
that is uh you know america will always
do the right thing provided they try
everything else first
and ultimately there is something about
the
the beauty of that system and by the way
i think to some degree is why america
has worked um you know the idea of
democracy is actually really [ __ ]
hard you know the idea of a you know
absolute democracy is actually not that
good which is why america is not a
democracy right america is a
constitutional republic so you know you
need a degree of federalism you need a
degree of freedom and you need a degree
of balance of power that america has
figured out but that comes with a lot of
constraints but that comes with a lot of
balances and weights
so that you know people don't go crazy
and try to you know write a new
constitution every 20 years which
happens in basically every other country
in the world
right
so
it takes time it's complicated but
hopefully we get to the right answer as
we have in the last you know 20 plus
years yeah
do you think that given where we are
right now america's future is brighter
or darker
than the past
and not so much can we do different
things to change that answer but just
if you take a snapshot of where we are
right now brighter or darker it's darker
uh like like
like the trend line is not positive
um
now i'm not saying this to to sound the
fetus to sound nihilistic uh that's not
what i want that's not you know when i
wake up every day like i'm trying to
like to hopefully do something to change
that but
i think we should recognize that
we're in a pretty dire situation uh
perhaps one that is unprecedented in
history um
and if we don't work hard to change it
then
then we're screwed
yeah what are the one or two things you
think are the most important to change
that path
well
i do think strategically like from a
geopolitical standpoint we absolutely
need to find ways to stand up to china
uh you know
for example like nancy pelosi going to
taiwan i'm not entirely sure that's
that's how we should do it uh after she
said she was going to do it i'm glad she
went uh
but
you know we need to you know to use the
chinese words like we need to hide our
capabilities and by their time to some
degree so that we sort out this the
supply chain situation the semiconductor
situation and we need five to ten years
to rebuild those things here and in our
in our allies countries um so we
absolutely need to fix that and then
quite frankly like we need to fix our
culture right like we absolutely need to
fix the culture the degree to which our
culture has been
destroyed uh in the last 10 20 years is
absurd like it's it's only starting now
to be clear to people you know because
you know the idea of being
you know bringing kids to you know a
drag drag queen uh you know
thing like was not normal and like that
that somehow like still like gets it
gets the average american
uh really upset um
so but we need to fight back and and
we're suing the early days of that i
always think just
go back to like the great depression
imagine that being a thing that a school
tried to do
people
there'd be
unfortunately there'd be violence yeah
right i mean they'd just be like get my
kid out of there uh and um you know i
don't think violence is the answer but i
do think that uh there's going to be a
kind of resurgence back my last question
for you uh it seems like um the american
political system uh has had a lot of
volatility you know one extreme another
extreme back and forth back and forth
can a
centrist
actually become president and uh get a
united front in america
without having to evoke war or some sort
of external threat to be able to do that
or do you think we'll just kind of play
this like ping pong game back and forth
between the extremes uh and the parties
will you know flip flop every couple of
years for the foreseeable future
i
i am very skeptical of the idea of
centrism as being a political goal for
someone
and i'm not sure
that it is possible in the environment
in the polarized environment that we
need in today that we're in today to
have someone like that really succeed i
mean talk about joe biden right like
president biden came in supposedly to be
that person right like he campaigned on
the idea of bringing out the tension uh
and then now he he's you know either you
know willingly or you know have become
captive of
this you know much
of far you know progressive left uh
so
ultimately i i don't think uh for better
or worse that you know the idea of
having like a centrist uh is actually
possible um
and like realistically right like to be
honest like i'm not even sure who that
person would be right like do we really
want mainstream democrats or mainstream
republicans who actually run the country
like i think there's actually bipartisan
agreement that those people suck for the
most part right like nobody wants them
um so
i i don't i think things will remain
polarized um
what i do think is you need to have a
president
with
actually more executive power than
before that is not authoritarian in any
way but to actually reduce the tension
everywhere else
so you need to have a president that
actually has the power
to say
you know soros funding every single
prosecutor so that then you know these
prosecutors progressive prosecutors
destroy your cities is not a good thing
this is why like what the scientists did
like we haven't really talked about this
but like what the sentence did like last
week or two weeks ago was one of the
most brilliant moves of any politician
in the last like five years what did you
do well so he soros had backed a lot of
prosecutors throughout the country right
like including a few that got elected
like somewhere in florida
and those prosecutors basically said
we're not going to enforce the law like
it was you know in the case of an
abortion law not to get into the whole
abortion discussion but like florida
passed a law that is actually much more
lenient towards abortion than most
countries in europe right so like we're
not talking about like mississippi or
missouri here like we're talking about a
law that is much more lenient than
europe and these prosecutors said we're
not going to enforce the law
and the sanchez basically said
you know i'm suspending you because
you're here to enact the law and you as
a prosecutor are not above the law and
therefore you're not fulfilling your
duty and according to the constitution
of florida you're suspended um
and so basically
he said here's your job they said i'm
not going to do your job and then he
said you're
fired whatever and uh
the
prosecutors have a problem with that
yeah pretty much though um it's
interesting so i do believe that you
know
for these issues to be fixed for a lot
of the issues we talked uh
about today to be fixed we need to have
a president that has the will to do some
things like that uh and it's this weird
dichotomy that in one in a few ways
you're actually you know saying that you
want a president that has more power
but overall that will probably calm down
tensions in america and it will bring
the overall
you know uh like size of the u.s
administrative state
you know it will shrink the
administrative state yeah i am uh
generally a pretty big optimist as i
think you are as well um and uh one of
the most uh pessimistic conversations
i've had recently uh i was uh uh walking
and uh
there's a couple police officers and um
started talking and and uh i said i
forget exactly what i said but they
basically made a comment like oh it's
gonna get worse
i said what and they said you know one
guy said i've been a cop uh in miami for
10 years and so i'm going to my 11th
year he goes and i've progressively seen
it get worse and worse and worse and
i said you know again there's a whole
bunch of complexity here but like why do
you think that and he basically made the
point that uh there's some ridiculous
rules i said like what's an example
and they've essentially were trying to
highlight to me that there's rules like
if they see somebody commit a crime
but it's not a violent crime they can't
chase them yeah
right and like again there's complexity
in that but i think the average person
says if
a police officer who again there's
plenty to complain about there's plenty
to say hey they're they're doing a good
job right uh but if they see a crime
occur
they just like what are you gonna like
wave to the guy well not only that right
kind of crazy you have and by the way
like not to sound too conspiratorial
here but i don't think the following
things are disconnected right so on the
one hand you have uh you know all of
these laws getting passed saying don't
enforce crimes crime you know san
francisco for example effectively
legalize crime and then on the other
hand you have the complete bashing of
that institution uh right like the
police right like you you basically had
minnesota thank god it got rejected but
the idea of like completely you know
abolishing the police right so like and
then all cops are racist now so like who
will ever want to work for an
institution like that right
the people who end up going to work
there once you've destroyed it are
probably the people that you didn't want
to be the police officers anyway exactly
exactly so i don't believe maybe that
sounds too conspiratorial but i don't
believe those things are disconnected
right uh and when you put two and two
together like that does not look good
yeah and i also think it's similar to
the immigrant uh thing where like the
immigrants who came to the united states
legally are the ones who are the most
upset about the illegal immigration uh
if you go to some of these police forces
it's the police who do the things the
right way that are the most pissed off
about the police officers who do things
the wrong way right and it highlights
like look there are absolutely 100 if
you go talk to a police force uh police
officers who do things the right way and
police officers who do things the wrong
way and unfortunately as in many things
the people who do it the wrong way give
the entire set a bad name uh
but the ones who do it the right way are
just as pissed off as the public
the thing though is we don't see that
yes right because they don't have a
platform they can't go on twitter and
say hey i'm a police officer at this you
know police department in you know a
random city in america and like the guy
down uh the locker room is doing you
know a b and c thing wrong and like it's
pissing me off yeah we haven't really
talked about this today but you know a
lot of the underlying issues with so
many of these things i mean you gave the
example of biology a lot of what's
happening with woke
culture and companies today is the fact
that effectively the system has
for for the last 20 years uh worked as a
minority rule so you have you know the
five percent craziest people you know
the wokest people
effectively say the most absurd things
and get that framed as the opinion of
the company as the opinion of the police
forces the opinion of the whole
institution right i mean we saw that
like for example like apple and antonio
garcia martinez right like you have like
a few individuals in this company of
like a hundred thousand people who say
oh this person shouldn't be here like
he's terrible whatever and the company
act because of the opinion like this
vast tiny number of people i do think
this is you know talk about optimism i
do think that this is becoming so
evident so clear
that we might see a sea of change
because
that doesn't work as well anymore
i i i couldn't agree more um
i've enjoyed this quite a bit uh we
didn't talk at all about village global
or anything else that you're doing uh
maybe just share with everyone uh kind
of the types of founders you guys are
looking for and what you spend your day
doing yeah absolutely if anyone is
listening and uh wants to spend more
time talking to you yeah yeah i know for
sure um always accessible you can find
me on twitter uh you know i want to be
clear my opinions here today and not
necessarily the whole opinion of village
global uh but uh super excited to have
that conversation uh in you know village
we're an early stage firm presidency
investing anywhere from 250k to a
million
anywhere around the globe not china uh
and you know uh really looking for
amazing founders right like we we come
in so early it's so common for us to
invest at day zero uh to back founders
when they have nothing just an idea um
that is even you know like some people
ask about like what metrics do you look
for it's like none because there are
almost never any um so you know
strong founders with a secret that have
an ambitious view of the future uh
that's that's what we're looking for
yeah i appreciate your time today uh i'm
a huge fan of of you philos global and
the rest of work you guys are doing so
thanks so much and we'll definitely do
this again in the future appreciate it
paul thank you